قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي احببته هجوما بطائره مسيره
اوكرانيه على قاعده
العسكريه في مقاطعه سلطوف الواقعه في جنوب
شرقي روسيا وافادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان ثلاثه جنود روس قتلوا جراء سقوط
الطائره المسيره يذكر ان هذا الهجوم هو
الثاني في غضون شهر على هذه القاعده وهي
الرئيسيه للقاذفات الاستراتيجيه الروسيه
للمتابعه ينضم الي من كيف مراسل الجزيره
تامر الصمادي مرحبا تامر
دعنا في تفاصيل اوثا عن هذه التطورات التي
اعلنتها كيف الميدانيه خاصه
فيما يخص تطورات الميدانيه محمد الجبهات
مشتعله في كل مكان تحديدا شرقا جنبا في
خرسون يتواصل القصف الروسي وفقا للسلطات
المحليه الاوكرانيه هناك على الاماكن
السكنيه وتحديدا الكره والبلدات على الضفه
اليمنى من نهر دنبر هذا النهر الذي يشهد
مواجهات مشعره بالمدفعيه الثقيله بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه على طول ضفتي
النهار تلك القوات الروسيه التي انسحبت
الى الضفه الاخرى من النهر من قلب المدينه
قبل قرابه شهر من الان السلطات المحليه
تواصل دعوتها للسكان بضروره النزوح في
اسرع وقت ممكن عملت على توفير القطارات في
الاضافه الى حافلات لنقلهم الى مقاطعه همم
وسط وغرب اوكرانيا وفي الحقيقه التطورات
ايضا التطورات ايضا متسارعه في همم يعني
منطقه التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
تحديدا ريف زبروجا الجنوبي القصف
الاوكراني كما تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه
يتواصل على مدينه ميليتوبيل وتوك ماك حيث
تتواجد القوات الروسيه هناك هو خلال
الساعات الماضيه قالت بالفعل هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه بانها تواصل صد هجوم همم مستمر
للقوات الروسيه على اكثر من جبهه في
دانيات سكوالوجان وتحدثت ايضا عن
صدها هجوما باتجاه باخموت والحديث عن اكثر
من 20 منطقه بلده قريه تتواجد فيها القوات
الاوكرانيه تتعرض للقصف من قبل القوات
الروسيه يعني اقرت هيئه الاركان بالفعل
بان القوات الروسيه قصفت مواقع خلال
الساعات الماضيه تتواجد وتتمركز فيها
القوات الاوكراني الاوكرانيه هناك لكن على
الصعيد السياسي يتطورات السياسيه كان
هنالك خطابا للرئيس الاوكراني ايزلزكي
الليله الماضيه دعا في وكان الى مزيد من
الحذر الى الالتزام همم كل ما يصدر عن
الادارات العسكريه سواء هنا في كياب او في
المقاطعات الجنوبيه والشرقيه وقال يجب
عليكم ان تستمعوا للتنبيهات الجويه وان
تذهب الى الملاجئ وتوقع في الحقيقه الرئيس
الاوكراني ان يكون ان تكون هذه الايام
عرضه لمزيد من القصف لتجدد القصف الروسي
ولان ياخذ هذا القصف شده وتيره اعلى وان
يشتد لا سيما في عطله الاعياد همم الحاليه
واتحدث ايضا الرئيس الاوكراني عن جدد
تاكيده وحديثه عن امكانيه النصر المرتقب
هو في الحقيقه محمد من اللحظه التي عاد
فيها من الولايات المتحده وهو يتحدث عن
مصر وشيك كما يسميه وذلك ربما نتيجه ال-
ال- التعهدات الامريكيه بمزيد من
المساعدات همم العسكريه فيما يخص المفاوض
كامل الرئاسه الاوكرانيه تحديدا المفاوضات
التي تحدثت عنها القوات الرئيس بوتين
بالامس نهايه محمد
الرئيس الاوكراني قال بان روسيا غير جاده
في هذه
المفاوضات وان القتال على الارض سيتواصل
حتى تحرير كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه من
القبضه الروسيه شكرا
على التطورات الميدانيه وايضا السياسيه
اتوجه الان الى امين درغامي مراسل الجزيره
من موسكو مرحبا امين همم استمعنا الى
الروايه الميدانيه الاوكرانيه ماذا عن ما
تقوله روسيا والعلل احدث هو حديث عن احباط
هجوم بطائره مسيره اوكرانيه
نعم وزاره الدفاع اكدت مقتل 13
بسبب سقوط حطام طائره مسيره اوكرانيه
وقالت الوزاره ان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه
اسقطتها قرب مطار انجلز العسكري في مقاطعه
سراطف وذلك في تمام الساعه الواحده
و35
بالتوقيت المحلي من الليله الماضيه طبعا
الوزاره اكدت على ان همم كل اليات
العسكريه وايضا الطائرات في هذا المطار لم
تصب جراء هذا همم الهجوم الذي طبعا هو
الهجوم الثاني خلال هذا الشهر على نفس
القاعده الجويه في مقاطعه صارت هذه
المقاطعه التي تبعد باكثر من 450 كلم عن
الحدود
الاوكرانيه ايضا بدايه هذا الشهر وتحديدا
في الخامس من ديسمبر كانت كل قاعده دياجيل
في ريزان التي تبعد عن موسكو فقط بنحو 300
كم وايضا هذه القاعده العسكريه اي انجلز
في قطع تعرضت لهجمات
وطبعا كان قد هذه الهجمات كانت قد خلفت
ضحايا عسكريين وايضا تضرر عدد من الطائرات
خاصه طائرات تو الروسيه اي تو بوليف بعيده
المدى طبعا همم لافد في هذه الهجمات التي
باتت متكرره في الحقيقه هو انها بعيده عن
الحدود الاوكرانيه اولا وهذا يحينا على
تصريحات سابقه كانت قد صدرت قبل نحو شهرين
من مسؤول روسي في شبه جزيره القرم اللي
نذكر حينما ايضا كانت هناك بعض المواقع
العسكريه قد تعرضت لهجمات تقريبا مشابهه
كان قد قال بان ربما تلك الهجمات لا تنفذ
من داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه بل همم ما
سماها طبعا همم خرقات امنيه همم تقع
كاليتم اطلاق تلك الطائرات المسيره من
داخل الاراضي الروسيه وتحديدا قرب الاهداف
التي يتم همم استدافها طبعا هذه التطورات
تاتي همم بالتزامن مع اشتداد المعارك خاصه
على جبهه بومباز
وهناك ايضا قصف اليوم تحدثت عنه سلطات همم
مدينه دمياط سلطان طبعا المواليه لروسيا
التي قالت بان هناك ضحايا في من المدنيين
جراء تعرض احياء في جنوب وفي غرب المدينه
لقصف بصواريخ جراج كل ذلك طبعا يتزمن ايضا
مع تواصل المعارك خاصه على جبهه ضخموت حيث
تقول القوات الروسيه هناك انها تحاول
اختراق دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني والعوده
الى تلك المناطق التي كانت سيطرت عليها في
وقت سابق داخل مدينه ضخم موت امين من
موسكو شكرا جزيلا